Ich bin ein Schauspieler, der in der Zeit nicht mehr mit mir war. Ich bin ein Schauspieler, der in der Zeit nicht mehr mit mir war. Ich bin ein Schauspieler, der in der Zeit nicht mehr mit mir war.
und zwar in seiner wichtigsten Funktionalität, auf unter 1% eingeschränkt. Dann ist es einfach funktional kaputt.
Ich hab da immer Mario Bart vor meinem geistigen Auge, wenn ich das höre. Und der sagt, kennt ihr das? Ist funktional kaputt. Kennt ihr das? Internet? Kennt ihr das? Kennt ihr das? Ist kaputt. Funktional.
Frau war wieder shoppen. Den ganzen Volumen aufgebraucht.
Ein schönes Lied gibt es bei iTunes für eine Mark. Und die Einnahmen davon kommen einem guten Zweck zugute. Kommen einem sinnvollen Zweck zugute. Sehr schön. Werden nämlich durchgereicht an die digitale Gesellschaft.
Genau, da läuft auch eine Kampagne und auch nicht erst seit heute. Die ist aus meiner Sicht auch ganz, war teilweise ziemlich humoristisch geraten. Also es geht auch nicht.
Das sind diese Werbeplakate, die überall durchs Netz fliegen.
Ja, die sind ziemlich lustig. Es geht auch nicht nur um die Telekom. Also wir haben natürlich vergleichbare Probleme, die uns da drohen, auch von anderen Anbietern.
Na das werden alle so machen.
Na und im Mobilfunkbereich haben wir den heute schon, ja.
Wobei Mobilfunk schon noch mal was anderes ist.
Ist anders natürlich und wir haben auch einen anderen Markt da, das sollte man nicht vergessen. Also wir reden...
Das wird ja auch immer begründet mit tatsächlich dem Markt, dass das ja ein Markt ist und dass man auf einen Markt den Einzelnen nicht vorschreiben kann, was sie anzubieten haben. Und das Problem ist, dass das für den Mobilfunk durchaus zutreffen mag. Da hat die Bundesnetzagentur auch dafür gesorgt, dass jeder ungefähr gleichgroße Stück am Frequenzkuchen hat, seine Basisituation aufbauen kann. Und so im Groben und Ganzen die Bedingungen für alle vier Netzbetreiber, das ist T-Mobile, das ist Vodafone, das ist Telefonica O2, das ist E-Flux und deren Resellerinfrastruktur, dass die sich das aufteilen können, dass da jeder gleiche Chancen hat. Das sieht im Festnetz komplett anders aus. Da gibt es eben die über mehrere Jahrzehnte vom Steuerzahler noch in Staatshand in den Boden gebuddelten Kupferkabel, die dort liegen sozusagen die letzte Meile zum Kunden hin. Also das, was von dem Telekom-Scheidkasten auf der Straße zu euch in den Anschlussplatz im Keller und zu Hause ins heimliche Wohnzimmer geht. Diese letzte Meile, das ist sozusagen größtenteils über 99 Prozent alles Telekom.
Also bis heute, obwohl der Markt liberalisiert werden sollte.
Da gibt es natürlich für alle Anbieter, die das haben wollen, die Möglichkeit sich das zu kaufen. Das nennt sich dann Teilnehmeranschlussleitung. Die mieten dann sozusagen für ein Zehner von der Telekom den Kupfer zwischen der Telefonlose bei dir zu Hause bis zum Verteiler. Und können dann da ihr eigenes Equipment dranhängen. Können sich also in die Telekom-Vermittlungsstellen ihre eigene Hardware reinstellen und dann dort der Telekom-Konkurrenz machen.
Ich könnte also, wenn jetzt alle hingehen und sagen, wir drosseln jetzt alles, könnte ich eine eigene Firma gründen, die sagt, ich lief euch jetzt Internet nach Hause, ich drossel nicht, würde das sauber kalkulieren und dann würde das meinetwegen 50er-Kosten oder so, aber dafür hättest du dann wirklich...
Dann kannst du sozusagen der Telekom-Konkurrenz machen, indem du ihr diese Leitung abmietest und indem du der Telekom Geld für Hardware zur Telekom stellen gibst, dann kannst du dann der Telekom Konkurrenz machen.
Und stell dir vor, das ist natürlich auch die Hoffnung der Marktliberalen, denn der Markt wird's ja richten. Nicht wahr? Da steht ja auch so ein Koalitionsvertrag.
Der Markt wird's richten?
Ja, naja, ein bisschen. Also, das ist ja eklig formuliert.
Wir einigen uns auf, der Markt wird's richten.
Ich glaube, jetzt hat das Motto, wenn ich mich recht erinnere, oder?
Der Markt wird's richten.
Marktkonforme Demokratie.
Marktkonforme Demokratie. Marktgerecht, glaube ich. Marktgerecht. Das hat Merkel mal gesagt.
Nee, aber der Witz ist halt, dass die da quasi Monopol haben und ja, also um ihnen da Konkurrenz zu machen, muss man sich ihre Infrastruktur bedienen.
Aber die Art und Weise und die Kosten, die man da hat, um sich der Infrastruktur zu bedienen, die sind wiederum gesetzlich geregelt.
Die sind von der Bundesnetzagentur tatsächlich reguliert. Die reguliert zum einen sowas, die reguliert auch die Kosten, die Netzbetreiber untereinander bei Sprache haben. Also die sagen zum Beispiel, wie viel eine Minute Telefonie in Mobilfunknetzkosten darf bei der Netzübergabe und so zeugs.
Oder auch die Rufnummern, also all die Fragen, um die sich die Kunden auch immer streiten. Wir hatten in der Unkeitkommission den Präsidenten der Bundesnetzagentur, der heißt Matthias Kurth, auch mal zu Besuch und konnten an den einige Fragen richten. Auch in Bezug auf die Regulierung, wie er sich das in Zukunft vorstellt, aber auch in Bezug auf die Kapazitätsgrenzen, die es da gibt, also die Engpässe. Und tatsächlich ist es so, dass die Bundesnetzagentur im Bereich der Mobilfunksituation eigentlich gar nichts reguliert, weil sie einfach sagt, na da ist ein Markt, wir erheben da auch keine Zahlen. Sie wissen also auch gar nicht, wann sind denn eigentlich Engpässe, wie sehen die aus. Und überhaupt nur im Festnetzbereich tätig werden und da eigentlich auch nur nachwirkend. Also häufig ist es so, dass sie reagieren auf Beschwerden, also wenn sich Leute beschwerden, aber nicht unbedingt präventiv tätig werden. Das war so ein bisschen die Message, die er uns da gab. Na ja, kann man sich natürlich auch mal ansehen, wie die Bundesnetzagentur zusammengesetzt ist. Und wer das sagen hat, wundert man sich dann auch nicht mehr.
Lass mal ein bisschen telefonieren, oder? 0331 77 91 10 der Thomas hat anrufen, oder Thomas?
Fio, ich wollte hinzufügen, dass wir ja das Internet auch zur politischen Beteiligung nutzen wollen und können, zum Beispiel Bundestagsreden hören und das Beispiel jetzt hier vom Herrn Ull zu dieser OZAP-Stift, die Differenz zwischen der Rede und dem Papier, die war ja sehr erheiterndlich, fand.
Du spielst jetzt an auf die Rede, die erhielt nach dem Aufdeckung der Staatstrojaner, wo dann man fanden Protokollen, schriftliche davon und das schriftliche Protokoll hat wich ab von der gesprochenen Rede, die aber gestreamt wurde, die konnte man sich ansehen. Die erklärt jetzt nur, wenn die Leute dich...
Aber das ist ja oft, dass das abweicht. Das ist aber ganz interessant, wie viel Bandbreite braucht eigentlich DE-Mail?
Also derzeit sehr wenig, benutzt ja kaum jemand.
Kann man mit 384 Kilo wird wahrscheinlich nur nutzen.
Ja, würde ich auch sagen.
Das heißt, das Argument fällt auch aus. Ich dachte, ich hätte jetzt irgendwie eine tolle Interaktion gefunden.
Wollte irgendjemand in einer Türkei ins Internet Video auch möglicherweise multimediale Inhalte per DE-Mail versenden?
Das Problem ist aber tatsächlich schon, wenn in einer Familie, die alle sich ein 100 Gigabyte Paket teilen müssen und die kleine Schwester mit YouTube am Anfang des Monats verwallert und am Ende des Monats die große nicht die Telelearning-Video-Tutorials von ihrer Uni gucken kann, dann ist das einfach ein soziales Problem, was du darauf weißt.
Die Perspektive, so eine Welt, wie die FDP sie gerne hätte, wer am meisten zahlen kann, kriegt die besten Dienste.
Also was die Telekom möchte, sie drosseln ja nicht auf ein Niveau, wo das noch gehen würde. Sie drosseln ja auf eine Schwierigkeit.
5 Megabit oder 10 Megabit oder was auch immer, oder 10% deines Anschlusses oder 5%, ne das ist unter 1%.
So, sie drosseln auf ein Niveau, wo es wirklich schmerzt und wo du es nicht mehr nutzen kannst.
Und wo man die Telekom-Seite mit den Bildern nicht mehr richtig aufrufen kann.
Aber das ist ja ehrheulig, das ist kein Problem.
Garantiert, weil wenn du die Telekom-Seite aufrufst mit deinem Telekom-Anschluss, dann geht das noch schnell.
Wie war das? Eine Minute sonst was mit 348 Kilobit die Telekom-Seite?
Ja, aber wenn du in deren Netz unterwegs bist, dann werden sie es garantiert nochmal. Ah, der hat unsere Seite gepinkt, wir regeln mal kurz hoch. Und zack, wieder aus.
Vielleicht werden wir damit auch diese blöden, die ganzen Banner weg. Kriegen wir die weg? Also die anderen Menschen und ihren Bauern.
Also die Bandbreite kenn ich nicht mehr, nur aus Hotels, wo das bewusst so limitiert wird, dass gerade noch so YouPorn nicht mehr geht, damit die Leute die Fernsehkanäle mit dem Pay-TV-Programm im Hotel gucken und nicht das aus dem Internet ziehen. Das sind diese 384 Kilobit, das ist genau so der...
Darf ich nicht mal von so einem Hörer zurückkommen, der eine interessante Anmerkung machte? Thomas, bist du noch da? Genau. Ah, gut, wir wollten dich nicht so abwirken, die Männern sind heute schwer zu stoppen.
Und über das Internet bin ich halt auch auf euch gestoßen, also ich aufs Chaosradio und die Bildung finde ich auch eigentlich sehr gut. Ich wohne in Isachsen, ich empfange das nicht über UKW, sondern übers Internet und das würde man mir halt verwehren, auch die Podcasts, die jetzt das öffentlich-rechtliche Internet stellt und man könnte jetzt argumentieren, dass der Staat dann dafür zahlen muss, aber mir wird auch nicht der Fernsehanschluss bei Hartz IV verwehrt, warum soll es mir dann auch verwehrt werden, das übers Internet zu machen.
Es wird dir ja nicht verwehrt, es wird dir ja nur erschwert.
Du musst ein bisschen haushalten, die Idee, also die Vision ist ja hier nicht, dass du kein Internet mehr hast, die Vision ist, dass du relativ einfach nachzahlst, darum geht's, es geht dir nicht darum, das Land irgendwie ohne Internet dastehen zu lassen, das möchten sie nicht, sie möchten einfach, dass die Leute...
Das ist halt eine verkappte Einführung von Volumentarifen, indem man die Flatrate so beschneidet, dass es keine Flatrate mehr ist, sondern das Ganze effektiv in einen Volumentarif umstellt und du halt für deine Grundgebühren Inklusivvolumen bekommst und das Inklusivvolumen jederzeit um weiteres Volumenpaket erweitern kannst. Das klappt immer so, ich finde. Das klappt schon hervorragend. Wenn du beispielsweise bei Vodafone, glaube ich, so dein Volumen aufgebraucht hast, dann kriegst du ja SMS reingeboten, hey, möchtest du nicht noch mal weitere und weitere?
Und wenn nicht, kriegst du 32 Kilobit im Mobilfunknetz, das ist überhaupt nichts, das ist weniger als ein 56k Modem.
Echt, bei Vodafone oder was?
Ja, bei O2 auch, bei bestimmten Tarifen, also draußen sind sie nicht auf 32 Kilobit.
Bei mir ist das auch, beim Handy, also ich hab mal eins von der Telekom, das kannst du nachkaufen. 64 Kilobit, geh mal hin. Na gut Thomas, ich glaub Thomas freut schon.
Das ist ja nichts, worüber du mich freuen solltest.
Das ist eine Sache, das ist doch, ich verdiene genug im Moment, weißt du, das ist halt...
Du freust dich darüber, dass du dein Geld ausgeben darfst.
Ich freu mich darüber, dass ich es mir überhaupt leisten könnte.
Ja, worauf Thomas hinausfährt, ist glaube ich dieser Grundversorgungsgedanke und die Idee, dass man unter einer bestimmten Bandbreite irgendwas nicht mehr so wirklich als Internet bezeichnen kann oder überhaupt der Bevölkerung so eine Art Grundversorgung zur Verfügung zu stellen hat. Das ist ja auch tatsächlich bei manchen Parteien eine politische Verorderung.
Die Mediatheken guck ich da an.
Na die hat er ja erwähnt, also jetzt, wenn du zum Beispiel Radio hörst, würde man nicht so...
Ja Radio geht ja, ist ja schmalbandig, aber guck dir mal einen Tatort an. Stream mal einen Tatort in dem HD, in dem der Tatort kommt, die anderthalb Stunden sind eineinhalb Gigabyte.
Thomas, was würdest du denn sagen, wenn die Telekom dir jetzt sagt, ja, ARD-Mediathek sehen wir ein, das hast du ja auch über deine Gebühren bezahlt, die ARD-Mediathek schließen wir davon aus, die kriegst du.
Nein, weil ich höre ja auch Podcasts, ich bin von den bösen iTunes Nutzer, die da so von sich Podcasts abonnieren und auch regelmäßig auch... Verschiedenste, also Deutschlandfunk, ich bin morgens in der Universität, da kann ich den nicht hören, also höre ich es nachmittags. Und das glät es halt runter, dann kann ich das nachmittags hören.
Und du hast ja so ein Paket, wo Bildungsinhalte und Öffentlich-Rechtliche dabei sind. Also die wäre für dich als Telekom-Kunde interessant?
Interessant schon, man muss es sich leisten können. Und dieses Video, was jetzt online steht mit meine Eltern haben kein Geld dafür, das finde ich dort ein Anstoßen.
Okay, also du hast da eine klare Haltung.
Genau.
Das ist schon mal eine deutliche Meinung.
Was zu der partizipativen Geschichte auch noch dazukommt, die meisten Kunden, eigentlich alle Kunden, die in VDSL, die in ADSL zu Hause haben, nutzen ja auch nur so die Hälfte ihres Anschlusses, weil du kriegst 250 MBit down, theoretisch bekämpfst du auch 25 MBit ab. Das ist in der VDSL jetzt pro spekso drin. Wenn man irgendwie nachguckt, bei bestimmten, bei bestimmten Daten, wer geht das, sieht man wie viel Bandbreite denn da zur Verfügung stünde. So und der das 25 MBit im Upstream und nicht nur 10, das heißt die Telekom nutzt die Hälfte ihres Netzes eh nicht. Weil die Kunden tatsächlich ja nur den Downstream haben. Also das ist eh schon so ein bisschen BTX und Steroids mit irgendwie, früher hatte man da 1200 baud down und 25 ab oder so. Ja, also das ist eh schon in einer Art und Weise beschnitten, dass es wirklich auf den Konsum zugeschnitten ist und nicht als Zugang für mündige Netzbürger, die selbst auch Inhalte produzieren.
Also dennoch, also die Netzhinterne Tätdebatte, die wir da so haben, die muss man glaube ich trotzdem ein bisschen kritisch betrachten, weil eine andere Form von Diskriminierung ist oder auch eine andere Form von Regulierung dieses Marktes. Wir haben ein Fakt, dass die Telekom nicht mehr nur Netzanbieter ist, sondern natürlich auch längst Content-Anbieter, Herteanbieter. Und diese Vermischung, die macht sich in dieser Neukalkulation der Tarife ganz klar deutlich.
Weil es eben plötzlich interessant wird, den Kunden bestehende Produkte einzuschränken. Also einen Schritt zurückzunehmen und zu behaupten, ja wir haben da Engpässe, wir haben gerade festgestellt, dass wir eigentlich mit dem Wasser haben, mehr Geld verdienen können, Engpässe haben. Ja und dann eben unter dem Stichwort Engpässe Dinge zu Geld machen, bei denen sie vorher kein Problem hatten, einem das so zu geben. Also das ist eine eiskalte Monetarisierung von Staatseigentum.
Ist ja nicht so, dass wir das nicht alle bezahlt hätten.
Darum fand ich es so charmant, die Spontanreaktion von Christopher Lauer, enteignet den Scheißladen, fand ich irgendwie ganz charmant.
Aber ist doch im Prinzip so, dass wir den eigentlich schon haben.
Das heißt Deprivatisierung.
Deprivatisierung und das würde ja reichen, die Infrastruktur zu deprivatisieren, den Rest können sie ja behalten. Die Hotlines.
Na ja, wir sollten vielleicht in dem Zusammenhang auch nochmal ganz kurz über Best Effort reden. Also wenn man über das Prinzip der Paketvermittlung redet im Netz, dann sind ja meistens die Best Effort Netzer. Das bedeutet einfach, dass man sich größtmöglich Mühe gibt, fair durchzuleiten. Und die Frage wird halt sein, ob man in Zukunft tatsächlich von diesem Best Effort Prinzip abgewichen wird. Dass man sich also unabhängig vom Inhalt und unabhängig von demjenigen, der es einstellt oder auch unabhängig vom Protokoll Mühe gibt, es bestmöglich durchzuleiten. Das ist ja eigentlich die Frage, die hinter der Netzetreite steht und die ja auch in den Debatten, die darüber früher schon geführt wurden, immer wieder im Mittelpunkt stand. Wir sind ja in Deutschland nicht die ersten. Die Debatte ist ja in den USA schon einige Jahre früher geführt worden, aber auch da geht es eigentlich eher mal so um die Inhalte, zum Beispiel beim Google Verizon Deal, über den damals hier gestritten wurde, wo der amerikanische Gesetzgeber war ein Abkommen zwischen einem großen Telekommunikationsanbieter und Google, über die Frage gestritten wurde, aber nicht wirklich um die Prinzipien des Best Effort. Die sind eigentlich deshalb glaube ich noch nicht Teil der Debatte. Würde ich jedenfalls heute so sehen. Also die eigentlich so den Kern der Netzneutralität ausmachen. Dennoch hast du natürlich ein erster Schritt zu diesem Entertainment Netz, wo man eben ganz klar nach Services und Dienstleistungen unterscheidet.
Du möchtest einfach nicht, dass dein Internetanbieter noch irgendwelche Aktien in dem Bereich hat, was du dir über diesen Internetanschluss anschaust. Das ist eine sehr unheilige Allianz.
Das hat einen klaren Interessenskonflikt, wenn dein Internetprovider ein Interesse daran hat, sich die Inhalte, die du darüber leitung transportierst, genauer anzuschauen.
Da müssen wir natürlich auch nochmal darüber reden. Es ist natürlich erst in den letzten Jahren überhaupt möglich geworden, die Inhalte so klar zu unterscheiden. Und die Technik, die heißt EP, Deep Packet Inspection, dass man also in Echtzeit in die Pakete insofern hineinschauen kann, dass man analysieren kann sofort, auch bei hohem Durchsatz.
Während das Paket sozusagen noch durch das Netz geleitet wird, wird das schon klassifiziert, in eine Traffic-Klasse geschoben. Das Gerät weiß, ist das jetzt Firesharing, ist das irgendwas aus dem und dem Zielnetz. Also du kannst da kategorisieren nach allem, was dir so einfällt. Also das Gerät kann im Prinzip alles. Das ist nur eine Frage, die du programmierst. Also ob du jetzt irgendwie sagst, werf mir bitte mal Firesharing in eine bestimmte Traffic-Klasse, werf mir mal Diensteanbieter, die ihre Netzzolle bezahlt haben in eine spezielle Klasse, werf mir Voice-over-IP in eine Klasse und mach das mal so schlecht, dass man es nicht mehr nutzen kann.
Wie so eine Weiche oder eine mehrstufige Weiche, die man einstellen kann.
Und mit der Klassifizierung kann man eben arbeiten. Da kannst du zum einen dafür sorgen, dass Leute noch Voice-over-IP nutzen können, während sie gerade Filesharing nutzen, was total dufte ist. Du kannst aber auch dafür sorgen, dass das Filesharing nicht funktioniert, dass das Voice-over-IP nicht funktioniert, es sei denn der Nutzer hat das entsprechende Paket dazu gebucht.
Klassischer Fall im Mobilfunkbereich. Also als Mobilfunkanbieter, ich habe kein Interesse daran, ich möchte Minutenpakete an meine Kunden verkaufen, ich habe kein Interesse daran, dass die sagen, ja wunderbar, ich kaufe 5Gb und ansonsten könnt ihr mich mal gerne haben. Ich habe nämlich hier Skype oder Voice-over-IP oder was auch immer. Also sehen sie zu, dass sie sich teure Hardware kaufen, um genau das zu verhindern. Voice-over-IP über 3G, wenn man da nicht noch einen VPN oder so drum schaltet und sich viel Mühe gibt, kriegt man das dann nicht durchgeschoben.
Oder zu sagen, mir ist euer 5Gb Paket relativ groß, ich klicke mir ein 50Mb Paket, weil ich nutze eh nur Instant Messaging. So ich zahle hier keine 10 oder 20 oder 30 Cent pro SMS, sondern nur zahle mein 50Mb Paket für ein paar Euro und mache da mein Instant Messaging drüber.
Was meinst du, was sie sich geärgert haben, als dieses WhatsApp auf einmal ankam? Auf einmal schreiben die alle diese WhatsApp Nachrichten.
Plattformübergreifend. Sonst kannst du mit anderen iPhone-Usern hin und her messagen, aber nicht mit den Android-Usern.
Da sieht man erst mal, wie schlecht das Angebot der Telcos ist, weil WhatsApp ist auch richtig doll schlecht. Also das ist richtig doll mies. Die Übertragener unverschlüsselt dein komplettes Telefonbuch in ihren Dienst rein. What the...
Ja, aber du musst einfach mal, dass wir so einen Facebook-Effekt benutzen.
Das ist klar, aber das demonstriert halt, was für ein Mindestniveau ein Service haben muss, damit die Leute nutzen, nämlich keins. Das Angebot der Telcos ist einfach mal so schlecht, dass sie nicht anders umhinkommen, als andere zu diskriminieren, um ihre eigenen Produkte loszuwerden. Du brauchst da keine große Innovation, um mit ihnen zu konkurrieren. So, und statt die Innovation zu bringen und was zu entwickeln und das Ganze voranzubringen, sagen sie, nee, es ist für uns einfacher da einzugreifen und das Geschäft der anderen Leute kaputt zu machen.
Oder noch ein Anrufer, den Stefan. Hallo, Stefan aus Hameln. Du hast einen Einwurf.
Ja, ich hab einen Einwurf. Zum einen finde ich, machen die Leute einfach zu großen Hype um diese ganze Geschichte. Also jetzt diese Drossel-Geschichte, die wird da püttelig aufgeblasen, weil das anscheinend echt wahnsinnig schick ist, dagegen die Telekom zu schießen, weil es halt der Marktmachrimus da irgendwo ist.
Die Telekom war die Erste, die da einen Schritt nach vorne gemacht haben. Ich glaube, es hätte auch Oda vorhin oder Arthur oder sonst noch jemand getroffen, der gesagt hat, wir scheffen Flatrates ab und machen da Pakete draus.
Das stimmt nicht. Kabel Deutschland hat schon über einem Jahr Schwierigkeiten diesbezüglich und hat das Publik gemacht, dass die auch drosseln und war damit auch in der Presse.
Kabel Deutschland drosselt selektiv und nur an dem einen Tag.
Und Kabel Deutschland hat auch kein richtiges Leitungsmonopol in der gesamten Bundesrepublik auf alle Telefonanschlüsse.
Es ist aber auch, sag ich mal so in Einführungsstrichen, Kabel Deutschland ist auch ein ehemaliger Staatsminister, ist auch im Wohnraum der Bundeskost ausgegliedert. Und wie gesagt, diese Drossel-Geschichte, das ist definitiv nicht eine Erfindung der Telekom. Die will auch um die Telekom sprechen. Das Ding ist, die Leute regen sich jetzt alle so auf, aber wenn sie mal in ihre Verträge reingucken würden, die sie jetzt schon haben, dann würde ihnen auffallen, dass sie jetzt schon längst eine Drossel drin haben.
Zumindest, dass sie unterschrieben haben, dass gedrosselt werden darf.
Richtig, macht die Telekom aber noch nicht.
Macht die Telekom noch nicht. Und die Telekom hat auch gesagt, dass sie das wahrscheinlich erst ab 2016 überhaupt technisch auf die Reihe kriegen könnte. Und das Zweite ist, wie gesagt, dass in den Bestandsverträgen jetzt schon, in den aktuellen VDSL-Verträgen, da längst schon eine Drossel drin ist. Also von daher ist das definitiv jetzt eine Sache, die da so wahnsinnig hochgehängt wird.
Entschuldigung, sie ist jetzt halt vorhanden. Also da wird ja jetzt nicht irgendwie künstlich aufgebauscht, was vorher schon immer da war. Die Telekom hat halt gesagt...
Also du meinst die Pressemitteilung der Telekom?
Die Pressemitteilung der Telekom, das ist was...
Das wird den Leuten jetzt halt bewusst, dass das so ist.
Das wird den Leuten jetzt bewusst. Vor allen Dingen, es gibt jetzt auch was, worüber die Presse überhaupt berichten kann. Vorher gab es keinen Berichtsgegenstand. Also vorher gab es keine Nachricht. Und jetzt ist es nur Nachricht geworden. Und dann wird halt über eine Nachricht gesprochen. Also diese Kritik, die du anbringst, die kannst du bei jeder beliebigen Nachricht anbringen. Also jedes Thema, das in der Zeitung oder im Fernsehen diskutiert wird, wird dann nach diesen Kriterien künstlich aufgebauscht.
Für so eine Sache brauchst du immer zwei Bedingungen. Das ist ein Grund so. Also die Umstellung von Flattoil auf Volumen. Aber man braucht auch immer noch einen Anlass, damit Leute wirklich einen Punkt in der Zeit haben, wo sie kollektiv zu der Kenntnis kommen. Nee, das ist nicht so. Und die dann halt auch äußern. Und der Grund war natürlich schon länger da. Aber jetzt ist eben mit der Pressemitteilung von der Telekom der Anlass da, mal darauf hinzuweisen, dass das nicht so richtig das ist, was wir eigentlich wollen.
Was es ja auch gab, das war vor ein paar Jahren, gab es mal diese Fair Use Policy von 1 und 1, wo du auch eine Flatrate hattest. Wenn du dir aber immer schön Volllast gefahren hast, hast du irgendwann von denen Post gekriegt. Und die haben gesagt, hör mal auf damit, sonst schmeißen wir dich raus, mein Freund.
Auch schon lange, ja.
Echt?
Telekom ja auch schon ziemlich lange. Wenn du zum Beispiel im Bereich FNTP oder so was, wenn du da weißt, hier zu viel Spam über deinen Account laufen lässt, dann kriegst du auch eine Meldung von der Post.
Aber meinst du es auch inhaltlich, also findest du die Kritik auch inhaltlich überzogen oder stört dich, dass es sich jetzt so an der Telekom festmacht?
Mich stört einfach, dass da so ein Wahnsinnshype drum gemacht wird, dass das Ganze irgendwo, ja, wenn man jetzt mal wirklich die ganzen Provider mal nehmen würde und würde mal gucken, vom Vergleich her, wie es aussieht, von der Qualität her, dann weiß ich nicht, ob da jetzt das alles dieser Hype so gerecht ist.
Das Problem, welches ich mal ganz kurz hier sagen darf, das Problem ist, dass ich keinen nennenswerten Betrag die Telekom mehr koste, unabhängig davon, ob ich meine Leitungen ausnutze oder nicht. Das spielt für die keine Rolle, die haben dadurch keine Kosten, insbesondere weil sie ein so großer Anbieter sind.
Nein, sie haben keine Kosten. Das ist ihr Laden, das ist ein Wirtschaftsunternehmen, das interessanterweise auch noch immer in Bundesland gehört. Also das ist ja nicht so, dass das ein Privatunternehmen ist, wo die Mehrheitsanteilshalter entsprechend Privatpersonen sind.
Das ist eine Aktiengesellschaft heute.
Der Bund hat eine Sperrmigurität, also 15 Prozent oder so was.
Bleiben wir doch mal bei den Fakten. Kostet das die Telekom mehr, wenn ich 500 statt 50 Gigabyte im Monat durch die Leitungen blase? Frag ich jetzt mal Nibler, der weiß das.
Nee, das kostet die Telekom nicht mehr, aber sie haben natürlich schon nutzungsabhängig eine gewisse Grund, dass das Mittel sich trotzdem am Ende raus. Es spricht nichts dagegen zu sagen, wenn wir die Bandbreite nicht haben, dann kriegen die Leute, die Filesharing machen, ein bisschen weniger Filesharing. Da würde sich niemand aufregen. Das würde jeder von seinem Internetanschluss erwarten, dass zu Spitzenzeiten halt das ein oder andere Protokoll, auf das man verzichten kann, dank Netzwerkmanagement, ein bisschen langsamer ist man aber immer noch telefonieren kann. Das wäre die korrekteste Anwendung von Netzwerkmanagement. Da würden alle Kunden sich total noch in den Bauch freuen, weil sie ganz genau wissen, hey, das ist zwar gerade eng, weil Stoßzeit, aber mein Internet ist nicht funktionar kaputt. Ganz im Gegenteil, das funktioniert noch hervorragend. Und mein Anbieter kümmert sich darum, dass eben mit dem besten Effort das Netz zur Verfügung gestellt wird.
Das ist nämlich best effort.
Genau das heißt best effort. Und da hätte niemand was dagegen, wenn die Telekom sagten, ja das mit dem Ausbau, das wird schwierig, 100 Gigabit Interfaces sind teuer.
Vielleicht sollten wir andersrum denken.
Dann dürfen wir uns jetzt nicht darüber aufregen oder was?
Nein, wenn man die Kritik ernst nimmt, müsste man auch die anderen Anbieter jetzt sich mal ansehen und die Vertragsbedingungen, was ja auch einige Leute jetzt gerade tun, gerade so bei der Aufregung, und ein bisschen Vergleiche herstellen. Das heißt auch dort die Vertragsoptionen usw. durchsehen. Wäre denn das aus deiner Sicht fair? Würdest du dich da sozusagen zufriedener machen mit dem Streit um diese Drosselung? Ist er noch da?
Hallo?
Also findest du das fair?
Drei gegen ein oder vier gegen ein.
Ich hab die ganze Zeit nichts gesagt.
Aber es ist auch nicht gegen, ich denke mal nicht, dass das sowieso eigentlich eine Meinung ist.
Also du findest schon, dass es okay ist generell mal darüber zu sprechen, wann wer diskriminieren soll.
Also das ist klar. Ich denke, diese Nummer mit diesem Kleingedruckten, ich denke, das ist so die Sache, dass das Kleingedruckte sollte endlich mal ein bisschen publik gemacht werden. Und ich denke, das, wo einem die Augen dann wehtun, wenn man irgendwelche Prospekte liest, wo man dann denken muss, dass ihnen die Tinte ausgegangen ist, dunkelgrau auf hellgrau auf weiß, da muss man auch sparen wegen der Volumen oder auch ganz modernen Sachen. Das kann es eher wenig sein. Da sind sie alle gut. Wie sie da sind, da kannst du alle in einen Sack packen und draufkloppen. Da ist keiner von denen besser.
Ich wollte dir nur noch einen kurzen Hinweis liefern. Du hast gerade eingangs erwähnt, dass auch heute schon eine Drossel-Klausel in den Verträgen besteht. Die bezieht sich aber auf eine 6M mit Drossel. Das ist zu wenig, um dir den Spaß am Internet zu nehmen. Und damit zu wenig, um dich zu motivieren, dann nochmal ein Paket zu kaufen oder sogar dann monatlich auf den höheren Tarif zu gehen. Das wäre das schönste dann für mich.
Da verweist die Telekom sozusagen versehentlich, wo denn wirklich ihre Schmerzgrenze ist. Also, dass sie 6M mit auf jeden Fall liefern können. Und das ist, was sie einem dazu gestehen in so einem Fall.
Was meint die Telekom damit, wenn sie sagt, alte Verträge sind davon nicht betroffen? Der Vertrag, den ich mit denen seit anderthalb Jahren habe, ist legal.
Also, da habe ich weiter. Da wollen sie, dass du den bloß nicht kündigst und zu einem anderen Anbieter gehst.
Ja, das ist das eine.
Bis die anderen Anbieter auch drosseln, dann drosseln sie meinen auch.
Ich meine, die sind sehr schwer behäbig da bei der Telekom. Die sind definitiv nicht flexibel, sind sie nicht. Das ist ja das Manko. Die könnten erheblich mehr wahrscheinlich. Und ich sag mal so, ich will auch mal jetzt eine Bresche schlagen für die Leute von der Telekom. Die machen, denke ich, mir einen relativ guten Job, wenn ich mir angucke, was die für ein Netz da aufrechterhalten in Deutschland.
Wer hat denn das gebaut? Hat die Telekom noch nicht gebaut?
Naja, der Punkt ist...
Nein, nein, Moment. Das geht jetzt gar nicht um Telekom oder wer das gebaut hat, sondern ich sag mal so, die Frage ist, wenn ein anderer Anbieter das hätte, ob der das genauso gemanagt kriegen würde oder so.
Ich muss auch mal eine Anzeige mit der Telekom brechen. Sie haben IPv6 momentan, sind sie am Ausrollen, also du kriegst an vielen, vielen Stellen in ihrer Netz, das ist zwar auch irgendwie ein Jahrzehnt überfällig, aber immerhin.
Das ist doch wie mit dem Wahlbürger und dem Kunden. Ich meine, die Leute, die bei der Telekom arbeiten, die kuckleleute und die Techniker, die können noch nichts für ihre Unternehmensspitze. Das ist wie unsere Regierung, die haben auch nicht gewählt.
Das ist eine Handvoll Leute, die das Scheiße baut.
Nein, das ist natürlich eine politische Entscheidung des Unternehmens nach ihrem Geschäftsmodell.
Und was ich mir auch mal so angucke ist, es gibt in vielen Gebieten zum Beispiel hier Schaltstellen, die erheblich mehr könnten. Ja, vom Ausbau. Da könnte VLSL locker laufen mit 30, 40 Mbit oder sowas und die schalten sie einfach nicht frei. Ich sag mal so jetzt gerade bei uns zum Beispiel in Hameln. Hameln hat fürchterlich damals schwer getan mit DSL, weil in Hameln fürchterlich viel Glasfaser in die Erde gekloppt worden ist. Von wegen, ah, Hype und so, wir knallen jetzt Glasfaser in die Erde und dann hatten sie das Problem, dass wir kein DSL legen konnten, weil sie mit der letzten Meilen Probleme hatten.
Das Opalgetto eben hab ich auch gesehen.
Weil sie dann nämlich diese De-Slams da nicht weit an die Straße gekriegt haben. Was haben sie dann gemacht? Haben sie auf jedem Verteilerkasten so einen extra Kasten oben draufgebaut und haben in Wirklichkeit einen Schritt wieder zurück gemacht. Anstatt den Leuten wirklich Firebird Home auf den Tisch zu legen und zu sagen, hier Leute, wir sind immer innovativ und wir legen euch jetzt hier meinetwegen 100 MBit, ein Gasfaserport legen wir euch da an die Tür rein. Was dann nicht mehr so ganz das Thema gewesen wäre. Ich hab echt manchmal das Gefühl, dass die wirklich Angst haben, so viel Bandbreite dahin zu legen, weil sie da irgendwie dann sozusagen so ein großes Fass aufmachen, wo sie nachher zubuttern müssen. Dass die wirklich konservativ da ihre Bandbreiten ausbauen, weil sie Angst haben, dass sie da berumpelt werden von den ganzen bösen, bösen Pfeilscherern und von den ganz bösen Saugern und Litern und wie sie alle heißen und da irgendwie nachher für die internationalen Netze, wo sie auch reinspeisen müssen.
Ja, aber die Netzübergänge und das Backbone sind nicht problematisch.
Punkt!
Da ist kein Engpass.
Hey, klar, kein Problem.
Ihr Chaosradio 189 geht natürlich um die Telekom und ihre Drosselungen. Nach den Nachrichten geht es da weiter drum.
Live und neu und gut. Live im Privatklub. Wann genau und wo genau?
Fritze.
Iswels, MC Fitti und Lindsay Stirling. Live und neu und gut empfohlen von Fritz.
Und das hört man um kurz in halb zwölf.
Die Betreiber des künftigen Flughafens BER in Schönefeld müssen die Anwohner besser vor Fluglärm schützen als bisher geplant. Das entschied das Oberverwaltungsgericht Berlin Brandenburg am Abend. Weil das Schallschutzprogramm des Flughafens zu klein bemessen ist, kommen auf den Flughafen jetzt mehr Kosten in Höhe von rund 300 Millionen Euro zu. In dem Verfahren ging es darum, ob Fluglärm tagsüber die normale Gesprächslautsstärke von 55 Dezibel in den 14.000 betroffenen Wohnungen überschreiten darf. Jetzt hab ich das Bett ausgemacht.
Das war ich.
Ja, weil ich ein bisschen zu früh dran war, aber ich hab noch ein paar Nachrichten. Ja, eigentlich hättest du das machen sollen. Ja, hast du ja auch. Ich hab's.
Ich hab's.
Lassen wir's. Ich hab's überhaupt nicht verloren. Ich mach weiter. Mach mal weiter. Die Bundesregierung hat sich bei UN-Menschenrechtsrat für die Ermittlungsfehler zur rechtsextremen Terrorgruppe NSU entschuldigt. Der Menschenrechtsbeauftragte der Bundesregierung Löhning sagte in Genf, die Mordserie gehöre zweifellos zu den schlimmsten Menschenrechtsverletzungen in Deutschland in den vergangenen Jahrzehnten. Die Vereinten Nationen mahnten, Deutschland müsse noch mehr gegen Rassismus tun. Die mutmaßlichen Attentäter von Boston sollen auch einen Anschlag auf den Times Square in New York geplant haben. Bürgermeister Bloomberg sagte dies habe ihm die Bundespolizei FBI mitgeteilt. Die beiden Brüder hatten dafür bereits Bomben gebaut. Zuvor waren neue Ermittlungspannen bekannt geworden. Neben dem FBI soll auch der Geheimdienst CIA schon 2011 von russischen Behörden über die mutmaßlichen Täter informiert worden sein. Zu Konsequenzen kam es aber nicht, möglicherweise wegen unterschiedlicher Schreibweisen der Namen der aus Tschetschenien stammenden Männer. Vor der Küste Westafrikas ist ein Schiff einer Hamburger Reederei von Piraten angegriffen worden. Sie haben vier Besatzungsmitglieder als Geiseln genommen. Das bestätigte die Reederei. Das Containerschiff ist demnach schon am Montag angegriffen worden und konnte seine Reise Richtung Senegal fortsetzen. Die betroffenen Crewmitglieder kommen aus der Ukraine, Russland und Kiribati. Um die Entführten nicht zu gefährden, will die Reederei keine weiteren Details bekannt geben. Mit den aktuellen Temperaturen. In Berlin-Köpenik haben wir es 12, in Charlottenburg 16 Grad. Forst meldet 10, Eberswalde 13, Potsdam 16 und Wittenberge 17 Grad. In der Nacht kühlt es auf 13 bis 9 Grad ab, teilweise ist es bewölkt, Schauer sind aber nur selten möglich. Morgen zeigt sich dann erst die Sonne, später ziehen dichtere Wolken heran und neben Regen gibt es örtlich auch Gewitter bei maximal 18 Grad an der Dosse und 26 Grad an der Neiße. Stadtverkehr Berlin, A100, Startring Richtung Neukölln zwischen Hohenzollern, Damm und Tintunnel, Innsbrucker Platz ist wegen einer Baustelle die linke Spur gesperrt. A113, Zubringer Schönefeld statt einwärts zwischen Schönefeld Nord und Adlershof gibt es eine Vollsperrung wegen Wartungsarbeiten, das ganze dauert noch bis 5 Uhr früh. Und auf der AWUS A115 sind die Auf- und Abfahrtenhüttenweg bis Ende Mai in beiden Richtungen gesperrt, gesperrt ist außerdem der Hüttenweg unter der Warnbrücke. Nach Brandenburg A20 Rostock Richtung Kreuz Uckermark zwischen Parsevalg Süd und Prenzlau Ost gab es einen Unfall und die rechte Spur ist blockiert. Wir wünschen euch wie immer überall wo es geht eine gute Fahrt.
Danke Jonte, 8 Minuten nach E12.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des Airbaby.
Danke fürs Zuschauen. Wir sind immer noch bei der Telekom und ihrer Drosselung.
Wir sollten vielleicht mal kurz zusammenfassen, was der etwas abgewirkte Stefan kurz vor den Nachrichten noch gesagt hat. Also glaube die die Forderung, die da so durchschien, war ja eine bessere Transparenz vor den Kunden. Also er hat sich ja so ein bisschen auch dann darüber beklagt, dass man die Vertragskondition nicht mehr lesen kann.
Ja, das ist überhaupt dieser ganze Umgang, den dieses Unternehmen dann auch mit seinen Kunden antagelegt. Mir ist völlig klar, dass sie das machen, um irgendwie Kohle zu verdienen, aber die verkaufen mich für dumm. Also weißt du, die halten mich für einen Idioten in ihrer Pressemeldung. Das ist das, was mich so aufregt. Meinetwegen kommt vorbeisagt, so Holgi, wenn du jetzt dein VDSL behalten willst, dann zahlst du jetzt mal 15 Euro mehr jeden Monat. Hast du jetzt davon, wir sind nämlich Monopolist. Dann sag ich im Zweifel, ach Arschloch, naja, hier hast du das Geld. Aber wenn da einer kommt und sagt, ich halte dich für doof und darum sorge ich jetzt dafür, dass du mir 15 Euro gibst, das trägt mich so auf.
Ja, ist die Polemik jetzt wieder zurück in unserer schönen sachlichen Sendung.
Entschuldigung, das trägt mich so auf.
Na ja, ich glaube, was hättest du denn gern? Möchtest du gerne so eine Art von Transparenz gegenüber dir als Kunden, die sagt, also Internet gibt es bei uns für diesen Preis, aber nur gedrosselt so und so. Wie genau hättest du denn gern, dass das auch jeder versteht?
Dass sie mich nicht verarschen, dass sie einfach nur sagen, wir haben uns überlegt, wir ändern jetzt unser Geschäftsmodell.
Das mit den Flatroids ist jetzt nicht mehr, wir machen jetzt nur noch Volumenpakete.
Weil wir das wollen oder weil wir können.
Wie wäre denn mit transparenten Modellrechnungen? Sie legen dir zum Beispiel vor, also in diesem und jedem Nutzungsverhalten im Schnitt werden sie so und so. Also könnte man sich ja auch vorstellen aus Transparenz gründen. Modellrechnungen. Also wahrscheinlich haben jetzt alle mal auf Drossel geklickt, oder?
Drossel.de? Drossel.de? Drossel, ohne das E, D-E. Da hat Sebastian Vollenhals eine schöne Seite gebaut, wo man für jeden einzelnen Tarif dann genau sehen kann, was ich da finde, wie lange man tatsächlich mit voller Geschwindigkeit surfen kann. Das ist dann so ein Stundenbereich oder so, ich habe gerade kein Netz. Stunden bis vielleicht maximal ein Tagesbereich, wenn man so mit 50 MBit daher surft. Und gleichzeitig hat er dann ausgerechnet, wie viel Internet man maximal nutzen kann, wenn man dann noch die restlichen 30 Tage mit 384 Kb da Vollgas gibt.
Und er hat ja nicht auch ein Video gemacht, der hat auch das Video gemacht, wo man die Telekom Seite sieht, wie sie lädt, wenn die Drossel an ist.
Wenn die Drossel an ist und das ist irgendwie anderthalb Minuten oder so quälendes Video. Das ist ganz schlimm, aber das ist guter Mann und gute Seite.
Stell dir mal vor, du hast einen Tippfehler drin und das ist erst mal die Navigationshilfe.
Wir sind ja schon ein bisschen bei Aktionismus angekommen. Jetzt sieht man schon, dass es nicht so viele Kreative sind, dass sie sich auch damit auseinandersetzen. Also wie zum Beispiel Drossel. Wir wollen mal ein bisschen darüber reden, was soll ich machen?
Ich habe hier das Wort noch stehen auf meinem Zettel, das heißt Gegenmaßnahmen. Genau, was machen wir denn da eigentlich? Wir haben übrigens jetzt ganz viele Anrufer noch.
Kündigt euer Spotify-Paket, zeigt der Telekom, dass er so zusatzbedingte Scheiße findet.
Die Idee ist tatsächlich aus mehreren Blogs, die jetzt darüber geschrieben haben, die haben gesagt, sie finden eigentlich schön den Service, aber sie unterstützen es nicht mehr und werden ihr Geld jetzt direkt Spotify geben und nicht mehr bei der Telekom. Und das ist auch etwas, was die Telekom als eine Art Kunden-Protest merken würde. Das könnte man... Genau, und ein direktes Feedback bekommen, während die Verträge ja in der Regel sehr langfristig laufen und Eidverträge ja ohnehin nicht betroffen sind. Insofern ist eine Protestform, fand ich interessant, dass man auch einfach sagt, okay, den Anbieter will ich eigentlich weiter haben. Ich bin aber bereit, da sozusagen wieder hinzuwechseln und nicht den Telekom zu zahlen. Eine andere Sache, die wir gerne als Aktionsform hier mal kurz ankündigen wollten, wäre verbunden mit der Hauptversammlung der Telekom, die ja demnächst sein wird. Und wir wollten mal fragen, ob es Aktionäre unter unseren Hörern gibt, die bereit sind, ihr Recht, Stimmrecht, oder? das Recht überhaupt zur Hauptversammlung zu gehen, abzudrehen.
Das ist relativ einfach. Man bekommt ja die Einladung. Die kam jetzt gerade raus, die Hauptversammlung selber ist am 16. Mai in Köln. Und bis Anfang Mai muss man quasi Leute bevollmächtigt haben. Und dann dürfen die dahin.
Ich hab leider keine, obwohl ich ja neulich erfahren habe, dass die Dividenden steuerfrei sind. Was ja schon mal ganz nett ist.
Die auch keine Höhenessteuer?
Ich lass die Dividenden direkt auf mein Schweizer Konto überweisen.
Man muss auch dazu sagen, dass die Idee nicht von uns kommt, sondern das haben aktiv Leute angesprochen. Wir haben da Sturmrecht auf, weil wir Telekom-Aktien haben. Tolle Idee.
Da würden wir vielleicht auch mal kurz, also wir hätten da auch mal eine Mail-Adresse, wo man sich hinwenden kann.
Du, Konstanze, habt ihr eigentlich auch eine Mail-Adresse, an die man sich wenden kann, wenn man euch zuhause sorgt?
Mail-ad-cc.de empfehlen, oder?
Info-ad-digitalegesellschaft.de Wird ausgeschrieben, habt ihr auch die gestern, oder habt ihr nur digitale Gesellschaft?
Info-ad, nee, Mail-ad-cc.de.
Wir klären das dann, also wir machen da round robin.
Ich möchte darauf hinweisen, dass das eine Adresse ist, die mehrere Leute lesen, also keine allzu privaten Personen, aber eine Kontaktmöglichkeit wäre schön.
Ja, wundervoll. Der Gregor aus Darmstadt hat angerufen. Hallo Gregor. Du hast dich bei der Telekom beschwert.
Ja.
Was haben sie gesagt?
Viele komische Dinge. Also es hat ja damit angefangen, dass ich da so ein bisschen Vitamin B zur Telekom habe und dass man mir da irgendwie schon im Januar gesteckt hat, dass da was kommt.
Hast du dieses Gerücht im Internet gestreut?
Gregor war es.
Das habe ich so unter der Hand bekommen und da habe ich auch gesagt, von dir wisst das auch nicht. Also die Telekom, möchte ich auch nochmal zu meinem Vorredner sagen, macht viel mit. Zum Beispiel das ATV6, das ihr angesprochen habt, das macht sie nur an IP-Anschlüssen. ISDN bis 2016, Grundversorger in Deutschland, irgendwie gesetzlich festgeschrieben oder so. Da war mal kein IPv6, nee.
Hat einen technischen Grund, das wollen sie da einfach nicht mehr bauen, weil das ganz fürchterlich schlimm supportet ist, noch von den Herstellern. Das war schon bei DSL ein echter Kampf, das hinzukriegen.
Und sie haben wahrscheinlich ein paar die entschiedenen Ressourcen.
Die machen auf Anschlüsse, wo ISDN noch dran ist, kein IPv6.
Hab ich anderes gesehen. Also ich kenne mindestens einen Telekom Anschluss, das ist ADSA direkt am HVT mit IPv6 und ISDN aus der S12 oder aus der ISD.
Definitiv.
Du hast gerade mehr Akronyme gesagt als Konjunktionen.
Ich kenne den ASB nicht, aber es ist in Nürnberg.
Was ich noch empfehlen kann für die Hörer ist diese Tim-Pritzloff-Serie Chaosradio Express. Hat man bestimmt schon gehört. Da ist Clemens Shrimp auch dabei und macht sich fürchterlich über die Telekom her.
Kennt er dich?
In diversen Folgen.
Hast du mal einen Song gehört? Hast du den gehört?
Nein, leider nicht. Ich hab erst etwas später zuschalten können. Ich war unterwegs. Und auch Logbuchnetzpolitik von Tim-Pritzloff hat sich jetzt auch schon über die Telekom hergemacht.
Ich bin da der Co-Moderator.
Wer ist mich da? Wo kommt die Stimme her? Den kenne ich irgendwo her.
Also was ich auch von der Telekom direkt gehört habe, ist, als ich das nämlich gelesen habe auf IZD, habe ich da gerade angerufen und gesagt, jetzt mache ich Dampf. Dann hat mir gesagt, Telekom Partner, VideoLoad oder Spotify, die Namen sind explizit gefallen, werden gar nicht erst in diese Drossel reingenommen. Der hat quasi schon offen gestanden Nachrichtssprache mit seinen Vorgesetzten. Nö, so Netz-Neutralität brauchen wir nicht.
Haben die dir zu verstehen gegeben, ob da schon andere vor dir angerufen hatten?
Ich war wohl mit einer der ersten.
Ah, ok, da warst du gleich gelesen und zum Telefonhörer gegriffen.
Ja, ich hab's auch erst nicht von Heisede gekriegt, sondern von so einer Apple-seitigen News-Webseite und dann gleich angerufen, was überhaupt auf den großen Seiten stand. Und auch auf die Frage hin, was sie sich denn überhaupt denken, wenn ich irgendwie, ich muss ja mit meinem DSL 6000-Ramm-Tarif, den sie mir da verkaufen, muss ich mich, kann ich nicht mal meine ganze Amtesteam-Libriothek herunterladen? Und er meint ja, Pech. Ja genau, ich gehe in die Straße an der LV, sie sollen mir eine DVD brennen. Das müsste billiger sein als die Pakistaner von der Telekom.
Was wäre denn, du sagst deine, du hast ja quasi was getan, nämlich da angerufen, hättest du Ideen vom britischem Aktivismus, was man dagegen unternehmen könnte?
Es gab ein schönes Beispiel in den Niederlanden, wo eine holländische Mobilfunkagentur da gesagt hat, WhatsApp macht uns das Geschäftsmodell kaputt und haben da fix mal den Port gesperrt. Dann haben die Holländer aber ganz schnell beschlossen, Netzneutralität gesetzlich zu machen.
Also du wirst einen Gesetzgeber appellieren wollen, naja, das sieht ja nicht so gut aus.
Also mit dem deutschen Gesetzgeber habe ich es jetzt nicht so sehr. Aber ich denke, wenn man zu Anbietern geht, die das im Moment noch nicht machen würden, würde das einen Zeichen setzen. Wenn aber die Telekom da mit Anstandsfluss durchkommt oder es zumindest so weit verschleppt, dass dieser Shitstorm, der gerade am Kochen ist, abklingt, dann haben sie gewonnen.
Na gut, das sind jetzt zwar nicht so die Top-Tipps, aber die müssen wir mal hinnehmen.
Gregor, schönen Dank für deinen Anruf. Ich habe hier noch einen prominenten Anrufer in der Leitung hängen. Kennt ihr den? Kennt ihr den? Namen Clemens. Echt? Clemens ist der Sänger von Funktional kaputt. Das Lied, das wir hier hören.
Ich habe noch eine schöne Idee gerade zu dem Vorredner. Das habe ich nämlich auch schon gehört, dass die Telekom sagt, oh ja, unsere Partner. Machen einen Vorschlag für den CCC. Ruft doch mal bei der Telekom an und sagt, hallo, wir haben ja auch eine tolle Webseite, wir haben auch die schönen Videos vom Kongress und so. Wir würden gerne Partner bei euch werden. Das ist so eine richtig schöne Hosen runter Nummer, weil entweder die Telekom sagt, nee, mit euch nicht, dann hat man natürlich ein geiles politisches Pfand in der Hand, dass man sagt, also nicht nur verletzen sie Netzneutralität, sondern auch noch die Leute, die bei ihnen was bezahlen wollen, suchen sie auch noch danach aus, was ihnen gefällt, oder wie ihnen sozusagen die Attitüde, die ihnen gefällt. Und wenn sie das nicht machen, dann müssen sie zumindest mal eine Zahl nennen, dann weiß man zumindest mal, was die Telekom vom TTC haben wollen würde, dafür, dass sie euch nicht prostet.
Das ist eine gute Idee.
Das kann man einfach mal machen, oder könnte auch Tim machen, aber wie gesagt, das TTC macht sich noch ein bisschen cooler.
Ich werde den Vorschlag gerne mal überdenken, möglicherweise werde ich den Beschluss der Mitgliedersversammlung ja beiführen müssen.
Wir machen hier so ein Internetradio.
Wir reden davon ja zumindest Gigabyte, klar, wenn man einfach an die Kongressfilme und so weiter denkt.
Ihr seid ja da richtig Content-Anbieter und da kann man den ja mal auf den Tisch legen. Das ist eine schöne Hosen runter Aktion, da müssen wir echt mal Farbe bekennen.
Möchtest du noch weitere Songs eigentlich zur Verfügung stellen?
Das musst du David fragen. Ich bin echt vollkommen schockiert. Die Leute twittern mir, dass diese Nummer jetzt in die Platzsäcke. Weil die einfach großartig ist.
Du bist sogar schon im Radio gelaufen.
Ja, leider war ich da noch nicht zu Hause.
Aber du hast wahrscheinlich schon gehört, dass du im Radio warst.
Das ist einfach kraftvoll. Wie sagt man.
Das ist einfach kaputt. Das ist nicht gedrossen.
Also dein Antwort, von der ist die Sendung rund gemacht. Technisch mein Fahrt mal rein. Aber offensichtlich hat er ja nette Probleme. Vielleicht ist er ja schon gedrosselt. Oder er ist ein armer E-Plus-Kunde. Also man weiß gar nicht. Die Telekom nutzt ja derzeit in dem Endkunden-Backbone maximal 60 Prozent. Kann man natürlich ganz einfach ausrechnen, weil alles jenseits des DSL-Anschlusses, also jenseits der letzten Meile, ist ja symmetrisch gebaut. Das heißt, du hast dann zwar deine 50.10 beim VDSL-Anschluss, 50.10 mit Download, 10.10 mit Upload.
Wo du auch eigentlich nicht 50.10 hast, sondern 125.
Ich habe es ja neulich mal gemacht. Ich habe es ja mal mit einem befreiten Wiflama, eine Fritzbox dran, eine ganz normale Fritzbox dran gehängt. Ich glaube bei einem Sender der Fritz heißt, darf man auch mal eine Fritzbox erwähnen.
Ja, ja, du hast es zweimal genannt, wir haben es gehört.
Ich muss mal sagen, ich habe einen handelsüblichen DSL-Router genommen und den war in einem befreiten Wiflama dran gefahren und der hat dann einfach mal 102 Megabit Download und 64 Megabit Upload gemacht. Aber darum geht es mir gar nicht. Die Infrastruktur dahinter, die die Telekom ja schon alles bezahlt hat, ist komplett symmetrisch. Die haben ja ihr Gigabit-Internet und das bauen sie nicht asymmetrisch.
Wir hatten das ganz am Anfang schon, im Backbauen ist ein Kapazitätsengpest auch einfach nicht da. Das bestätigen die sogar. Ich hatte das ganz am Anfang erwähnt. Der Bundestag hat die deutschen Provider einfach mal gefragt. Und dabei kam das klar raus.
Aber da können sie jetzt ohne auch nur für eine halbe Patchkabel bezahlen, sie müssen sozusagen noch Volumen frei machen. Wenn jetzt die Telekom ohnehin sagt, wir rechnen ja ganz, wir sind ja total fair jetzt, wir rechnen jetzt Volumenbasiert ab. Dann können sie auch endlich den Stock aus dem Arsch oder aus der Leitung nehmen und sagen, ja, machen wir mal hier mal den Upload auf. Weil es wird ja eh fair volumenmäßig abgerechnet. Und die Kapazität ist da, ohne dass sie auch nur eine Schraube kaufen müssen.
Ich glaube, wünschen würden sich das viele, für wie realistisch er jetzt ist. Also das ist ja nicht sehr realistisch.
Natürlich nicht, weil es ist jetzt auch so ein vorgeschrömmertes Ding, wo man sich mal wieder an den Haaren ziehen kann und sagen, hier, euer Argument ist eigentlich vollkommen aus der Luft gegriffen.
Oh, sag mal nochmal, dann können wir daraus einen Song machen. Bei dem Upload betrifft das würden sich sicherlich viele wünschen, klar.
Ja, sehr, sehr viele. Die ganzen freischaffenden Leute, Fotografen, das sind nicht alle. Auch, wie ist denn die jetzt anfangen, plötzlich Online-Backup zu machen? Das weiß ich jetzt nicht aus technischer Sicht, aber zumindest könnten sie dann.
Und glaubst du denn, dass uns Rösler und Eigener retten werden?
Also ich hab gehört, dass die SPD sich halt gesagt hat, ja klar, die SPD, ja.
Ich weiß nicht, wer uns zuerst retten wird, oder? Es gibt ja so eine Forderung, dass man die Bundesnetzagentur da aufwerten will, dass die also besser reguliert und sich anders einsetzt. Hältst du davon was?
Ich halte davon sehr viel, weil momentan weiß ich nicht, wofür sich die ganzen Beamten da, die den Hintern gerade platz sitzen. Die regulieren ja mehr, da bin ja nur Telefonie und das auch nur im Festnetz.
Den Interconnect-Preis und so weiter.
Aber nicht zum Entkunden.
Richtig.
Da passen sie nicht auf, was da gemacht wird. Und es wäre wohl hin mal gut, wenn zum Beispiel, das war ja vorhin schon angeschnitten worden, da habe ich euch dann schon zugehört, dass man mal aufhört die Leute zu verarschen. Mit irgendwelchen Flatrates, die keine sind und so weiter und so fort dran.
Ich bin angeblich, dass nur Flatrate heißt, was Flatrate-Ding sind, dass du dir irgendwie dein 5 Gigabyte-Paket im Mobilfunknetz buchen kannst. Das ist alles schön und gut. Aber das Flatrate zu nennen ist einfach eine Frechheit.
Und damit kommen wir zum Ende der heutigen Sendung. Nein.
Das wird aber ein kurzer Song.
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein.
Wir hätten noch einen kleinen Aufruf, der... Bitte. Ja, der ZZC ist auf der Suche nach jemandem. Es gab eine Entscheidung des Sächsischen Oberlandesgerichtes zu biometrieren Reisepassen. Und wir würden den Kläger bitten, sich beim ZZC zu melden.
Steht das nicht im Urteil, wie der Kläger heißt?
Das ist kein Urteil. Dem steht der Rechtsweg jetzt offen. Das hat die OEG gesagt. Und wir würden gern Kontakt zu dem...
Erklär noch mal, worum geht's?
Also jemand wehrt sich dagegen, dass die Fingerabdrücke in den Reisepass aufgenommen werden. Das ist ja auch auf anderen Rechtswegen geschehen. Und da gab es jetzt gerade eine Entscheidung des Sächsischen OEG. Also das wurde zugelassen hat, dass man überhaupt darüber verhandelt. Ja, genau. Und wir hätten halt gerne zu diesem Kläger Kontakt und würden ihn bitten, falls er gerade zuhört, biometrie... Bitte melde dich. biometrie.ccc.de Da würden wir uns freuen. Das ist jetzt aber wirklich das letzte, was ich ansagen wollte.
Vielen Dank, Constanze. Vielen Dank, Nibbler. Das war Chaosradio 189. Das nächste Chaosradio, nämlich Chaosradio 190, gibt's am letzten Donnerstag im Mai.
Der schöne Mai.
Der schöne Mai. Und jetzt gehen wir nach Hause.
Schönen Gruß an die Lille Lande.